So, what's all this listening
on a port business?
Well, it's like waiting for
a phone call.
There's a particular phone
number that will reach you,
not just anyone at your address,
but you personally.
That's how a port number distinguishes
different server programs running on
the same computer, like SSH on port 22,
or HTTP on port 80.
Let's see what port's available for
me to listen on.
Okay, here's port 3456,
I'm going to listen on that port now.
Just like NC-L3456.
[NOISE]
Hello.
Yes this is net cat.
All of these other phones, are ports
that no server is listening on.
If someone calls them, they're not
going to get an answer, instead,
they'll get the equivalent of,
this number is disconnected,
which is an error message called
a reset packet or RST for short.